this almost slipped by me but one of our
viewers Alan wrote to me about it and we
have to look at it
former Trump propagandist Stephen Bannon
actually sat down and did a long-form
interview with the failed former
president Donald Trump and it's
fascinating because this is this is sort
of like a vicious circle that we're
going to look at here
Trump tells many of the lies during this
interview with Steve Bannon
that arguably Steve Bannon created or at
least Bannon created the sort of
approach to politics that leads to Trump
being so comfortable telling these lies
it's really interesting to see I guess
you could say
the chef eating his Protege food I don't
know exactly what metaphor or analogy
makes sense so let's look at some of
this the formatting this is from
America's real America's voice war room
with Steve Bannon and their video player
is a mess and technologically it's all a
mess so I'm going to have to kind of
scrub through the video to moments that
my colleague John flagged for me the
first thing here is after years of the
whole crooked Hillary thing which Trump
recently reassigned to Crooked Joe Biden
Trump now is saying he never actually
thought crooked Hillary was that great
of a nickname which is weird because he
used it for half a decade I have old
problem but yeah I think they like to
say that for other reasons you know like
to say he's got a big problem now
because you've given him a nickname
I decided that
I've decided that Hillary's cooked uh we
can't do too much better you know I
always felt I never felt the Crooked
Hillary was a great name I thought it
was accurate but it never flowed like
some of the other half letters in here
from Bill Clinton you talk about it so
let's be really Frank okay do you think
when Bannon says that this this
interview was clearly done the day after
the rally at which Trump announced I'm
changing crooked Hillary to Crooked Joe
Biden do you think Bannon really thinks
that it's a big deal for Trump to change
the nicknames or is Bannon just playing
the sycophant suck up
that people around Trump are expected to
play uh I don't know I don't know the
answer to that all right let's now go
and bear with me here this is just the
way we're gonna have to do it next Trump
says that Rudy Giuliani was the best
mayor of New York ever and that New York
has now collapsed which is news to
everybody in New York yeah
went away from his policy of guns you
know what he was doing with the gun
stuff which basically was started by
Rudy look Rudy was the greatest mayor in
the history of New York and the crimes I
mean I don't know how you were there you
were there when the city started to
collapse I saw it all I saw it collapse
I saw it come back Rooney song and
you've seen a collapse again now it's
collapsing again yeah now it's at a
level and the one thing that's different
we had a very powerful police force that
wasn't being utilized now many of those
great policemen and women have left and
Gone to Texas it's mostly not true and
NYPD is actually doing fine but remember
that there's actually some interesting
political history here which is that
Rudy Giuliani benefited uh dramatically
uh and it's crazy to say it because it
was such a tragic event Rudy Giuliani
benefited dramatically in the way that
George W bush did
from 9 11 right George W bush saw 80
plus percent approval in the immediate
wake of 9 11 squandered it with the Iraq
War and Rudy Giuliani also became mayor
911 and ultimately it became all he
talked about for for about a decade
um but that is certainly a uh a claim
that New York is collapsing which is
hard to find anywhere as far as data or
facts are concerned Trump pulling out
the idea that America has gone communist
and what's really interesting to me
about this is you'll say well but David
Trump's been saying America's communist
for you know since Joe Biden the day Joe
Biden was inaugurated what's interesting
is to see Bannon in the context of
having to react to it one of the
greatest and I think if we win in uh 24
I think it's going to be when we win a
24 yeah the country can't take I don't
think it can take it no I don't think I
don't think we're going to have a
country you know this is a businessman I
don't think well even as a politician
they've weaponized you would know this
very well they've weaponized the justice
department they've weaponized the FBI
they're doing things that are communist
country would do a Marxist country would
do it's a very did you ever think this
country will get to that I never thought
it would be that bad and you've dealt
with some tough people yeah now here is
where I know Bannon is just doing the
sycophant suck up stuff Bannon Trump may
not be smart enough to know that there's
nothing Marxist going on in the United
States
Bannon is smart enough to know that
there's nothing Marxist happening in the
United States and so that's where I
start to see this and say Bannon is
absolutely playing a character here
he's playing the sycophant suck up
character here's Trump with his covid
conspiracies for lack of a better term
talking about Hunter Biden and saying it
was Russian disability I always think
what do you think Putin is saying when
every week they came up with another
thing Russia Russia Russia they never
blamed anything in China because they
were all getting rich from China the one
way you can tell he's illegitimate is
the lack of respect
that they have for him throughout the
world now that's factually untrue
if you actually survey people around the
world
respect for the American presidency and
the country has recovered dramatically
since Joe Biden became president they
just lot they love telling this lie you
went to we went to Saudi Arabia I mean
the military's out the thing I think
they go he's in an SUV with a fist bump
the moolahs don't respect him the KGB in
Moscow does effective she who's right
here for the historic Summit no respect
for him it's been three days here we had
a great we developed a great
relationship no one's covered came it
was like you know that was that was a
step too far I mean that cost the world
millions of lives and about
60 trillion dollars so nobody can ever
pay for that the lives of 60 trillion
dollars but they'll pay something
they'll pay something you know again
would you demand reparations from China
you can't there's no such thing as 60
trillion dollars you could add 20
China's okay you can't but they cost the
world I figured it costs 60 trillion
dollars worldwide and you know millions
and millions of lives what came out of
the wall head lab you remember I was the
first one as I said came from the
Warhead Library it came right out of
wall hands so Trump uh you know kind of
Reviving that one then there's a moment
which I can't play in its entirety
because uh I don't want anybody to you
know have a medical event from watching
five minutes of this but he he starts
lying about immigration for five
straight minutes and it's really crazy
and take care of American citizens
people don't realize you also use
tariffs to help secure the border 100
the the Mexico started getting you know
well they would have never done it I
said to the president of Mexico who I
really like I have to tell you he's
great you know he wouldn't I don't think
to this day he's even acknowledged he
said that election was a rigged election
he said it happened to him 10 years
before and he's a socialist but you know
what uh he's a terrific guy but I said
listen uh we're building a wall and we
built I built hundreds of miles of well
that was my first hint that what they
wanted to do is let people pour into our
country from prisons from mental
institutions there we go what they have
only the best only the best only the
best insane asylum you know what I'm
saying yourself that Silence of the Lamb
type okay and I don't know why nobody
goes sir it's Silence of the Lambs not
Silence of the Lamb so continuing to
tell those very same lies about uh the
Border none of that is happening and
then he moved on to a new favorite
Target where he lies about electric
vehicles and the electric vehicle lies
are interesting to me because it's such
a silly scapegoat and it's so obvious
that this is the way that vehicle
technology is going it just seems like
one of these fights that's a very dumb
fight to pick it'll only work for a
little while everything's the opposite
of what it should be we don't want to be
energy independent we want to spend
instead of a dollar 87 a gallon we want
to spend nine dollars a gallon we want
to go to all electric cars that go for
two hours and then you get stuck in the
middle of a road and there's nobody you
might as well forget the car how do you
get it it doesn't have I mean quite
literally doesn't happen you know my
electric car's range is 330 miles uh
went New York City to Montreal all with
you know One Stop which was an optional
stop but for a diaper change not for me
but for the baby it why are they
attacking electric cars because they've
generated an environment in which people
like to hear it and like to see it
Without Really apparently understanding
the truth of it now no Trump interview
is complete without big dumps
I'll give you an example we're tough
enough to get this done I don't know
that's look the one thing the Democrats
have horrible policy but they stick
together
and they cheat the Republicans don't
want to achieve I said to a man in
Pennsylvania I love Pennsylvania I did
great I was up by almost 900 000 votes
all of a sudden I was even I said what
happened and you see the chart and then
it there was a dump big dump I mean it
was amazing yeah Trump was amazed by the
size of the Pennsylvania dump uh he did
attack Alvin Bragg I'm going to skip
over that even though I have it in my
notes he did attack Ron DeSantis and
that's another interesting moment here
and it's curious to see Steve bannon's
reaction to that we're going to take a
look at the DeSantis attacks and again
remember Trump obsessed with the santus
despite the fact that he's still not
announced anything because this is the
Donald Trump that America first met and
now you're under assault from everywhere
total assault total assault because
we're winning in the polls if I wasn't
supposed
to well the Sanctus is uh failing badly
Rhonda sanctimonious I mean you know
it's always bad you endorse somebody
he's dead he's he's over his politics
where he's going to be looking for a job
he'll be lucky to get a job
comes to me begs me for a endorsement I
give it to him he ends up winning the
election winning the nomination winning
the election by numbers that you
wouldn't believe I mean he was so far
down he was gone
and then they shout to him a couple of
years later will you run against the
president I have no comments now no
comment means the answer is yes now that
is what this is all about that is the
the most honest thing Trump has said in
a long time this is the narcissism
full-fledged how dare DeSantis not
simply say I will not challenge our
great orange leader Donald Trump that's
what Trump expects that's what Trump
considers to be loyalty all right last
thing continuing to make these silly
promises about how quickly he will solve
the situation in Ukraine he would have
never gone into vice president in a
million years and even the Democrats
they did a poll the other day 94 say if
Trump was President you wouldn't have
that horrible catastrophe and so many
people have been killed many more than
they report when they blow up a city
Steve and you see all those big
buildings and then they say two people
were injured it's it's much worse than
anybody understands I would have that
settled in 24 hours yep and of course
and this came up in my interview with
Lex Friedman the insistence on Putin
wouldn't have invaded Ukraine had I been
president it's not really the big gotcha
that some of them believe it to be
because it's completely plausible that
Putin would have seen other ways to grow
his power if Trump were president rather
than Joe Biden so a bizarre interview
with Stephen Bannon but where Trump is
right and at the end of the day when the
rubber meets the road it's the numbers
that matter uh the polling one of our
sponsors today is fume not everything in
a bad habit is wrong so instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad part from your habit
fume is an Innovative award-winning
device that does exactly that fume is
not electronic there's no Vapor or
harmful chemicals fume is just a
delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fume success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save 10 percent when you get
the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is
down below